let's talk about this Anthony fauci
fraud Anthony crunchy he went on CNN
yesterday to talk about what Ron
DeSantis is doing right here in Florida
and he's clearly nervous and just watch
if you want to see the beautiful
Perfection of the mainstream Media Watch
as the interviewer asks him an extremely
loaded question and clearly is on his
side in this whole thing so politicized
as as covet 19. I mean you've found
yourself we've talked about this many
times at the center of some of that
angry debate Elon Musk just came at you
and attacked you but the latest now Dr
fauci is Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
he's now asking the Florida Supreme
Court to Green Light an investigation
into in the way he put it is any uh any
and all wrong doing in Florida with
respect to covid-19 vaccines
what's your reaction to that
I don't have a clue Kate what he's
asking for I mean we have a vaccine that
unequivocally is highly effective and
safe and has saved literally millions of
lives that's a very difficult situation
you're absolutely correct it has been
politicized and it has been politicized
in a way that has actually caused lives
because if people don't get vaccinated
which unequivocally is life-saving
because of political ideology everything
he said there is a lie it never stops
with the guy the balls on this
bureaucratic buffoon are large he has
large balls I'll give him that a couple
things there first off the vaccines are
not highly effective fact check me fact
Checkers Joe Biden last June if you get
the vaccine you will not get nor
transmit covid that is what wolensky at
the CDC told us that is what fauci told
us that is what virtually every
government official told us before this
if you were vaccinated against something
before the covid vaccine you did not get
the thing that's what we all thought
vaccine meant Oh you get a bat you're
vax from polio you ain't gonna get polio
polio polio vaccine polio that way polio
doesn't go this way it doesn't get in
the system but they've literally
literally changed the definition of
vaccine because the coveted vaccines do
not work as every previous vaccine so
that's one thing then he says that it
saved millions of lives there's just no
evidence of this there is no long-term
evidence of this there may be some
evidence that people of a certain age
with some other diseases got some
temporary protection from covid Perhaps
Perhaps but there is no evidence that it
has saved millions and millions of lives
I don't think honestly at this point
that there's any evidence had we done
nothing and I really mean that
absolutely nothing we would have known
that there's this there's this kind of
flute like thing going around the world
and everyone's just going to kind of get
it and just remember everybody take care
of yourself don't don't forget to drink
a little water get a little sunshine
exercise every now and again maybe get
off your ass uh I think things probably
would have been better well I think
things for sure would have been better
at a sort of psychological level after
the the insanity and the gaslighting of
the last two and a half years uh and
also this idea that we're the ones that
politicize this thing we politicized it
by pushing back on the nonsense that's
what he's saying these people politicize
it meaning the Republicans or
conservatives whatever it's like wait a
minute wait a minute
first off in the world we live in now
everything is political but if you shut
people out of their jobs if you don't
let kids go to school if somehow
teachers union seem like they're in
cahoots with the uh with the science uh
the scientists and all of the the CDC
and the NIH and everything else you guys
made it political we're just calling out
your BS that's all it is